[Music]
welcome to the week in 60 minutes
brought to you by spectator tv
recorded on thursday march the 4th
on this week's show there was a uk
budget this week you probably noticed
the spectator's crack team of economic
and political journalists
will break it down for you the
successful vaccines rollout may also
produce an economic recovery more
quickly than we could have hoped for i
would be
speaking to the statistician david
spiegelhalter
about the vaccine effect meanwhile the
smp
civil war rumbles on nicola sturgeon is
still scotland's first minister
but as the hollywood elections loom is
she now the walking wounded
and finally could president macron
lose next week's french sorry and
finally could president macron
lose next year's french presidential
election
i'll be chatting to the spectator south
of france correspondent jonathan miller
about the president's growing problems
all that to come
in the next hour as always if you
subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel and why wouldn't you
it's free you'll never miss a program
just click the subscribe button
at the bottom right of the screen a very
special thanks to
charles stanley for their continuous
support of the week in 60 minutes this
year
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms
one of the oldest companies on the
london stock exchange we're delighted
to be partners with them now lots to
come up
on the budget but first let's get an
update on where we are
with the vaccine the uk continues to
lead
europe on the scale and efficiency of
the vaccine rollout
uh of course it's in our interest that
everybody in europe and elsewhere is
vaccine
is vaccinated but it's good to see
britain doing something right
and who better to break down the
significance of the numbers than
professor
david spiegelholter he's a statistician
at statistician
and chair of cambridge's winton center
for risk and evidence communication
professor
welcome back to spectator tv let me
begin with a general question
is it right in your view to to see
uh vaccine policy in some ways is now
the government's major economic policy
i without this vaccine i mean we have
knows what how we'd be able to get out
of this this epidemic especially with
the new variants coming along
so it must go absolutely hand in hand
with
opening up society and the rebuilding of
the economy
and um and that's why the comparisons
between what's happening in the uk and
what's happening
certainly in the rest of europe become
so interesting
tell us where we are with the vaccine
now
i as i understand it quite early on the
british government
obviously taking scientific advice
deciding that it would give priority to
getting as many
of the target groups as possible the
first dose
it knew we'd need a second dose and
weeks later but the
idea was rather than doing the first
then the second to do as many first
first first as possible
and then follow up with the second that
i think has been a vindicated
strategy there were three bold decisions
made at the beginning of the vaccine
rollout and
strongly influenced by the scientific
opinion from
from jcvi the the committee responsible
the first in terms of the prioritization
which is strictly based on a statistical
analysis
of who is most at risk and so there's a
absolute
clear objective to save the maximum
number of lives
and which is also the number of years of
life lost as well so
complete focus on that and that are two
implications
three implications first of all who got
the vaccine first
secondly that they wanted to get as many
first jabs into as many arms as possible
with a delay on the second dose until
12 weeks and this was very controversial
criticized by other
other countries as well and and thirdly
the idea that the astrazeneca vaccine
although the trials had not
you know included many people over 65
was fined to give to over 65
those three um bold controversial
decisions
have been all been vindicated and have
led to the
staggering success of our vaccine
rollout and the clear signs of it of its
effectiveness
now now tell me who who have we done who
who is now covered by the vaccine even
if it's just
the first dose because i think that
still gives you quite a high percentage
of efficacy
uh and who's going to be next well we
worked down through
you know the people in care homes then
the in the over 80s the over 70s
people on the clinically extremely
vulnerable list and so on
and so very high percentages in these
groups have been vaccinated
we're now down to the sixth sixties i
got myself done which is great just in
you know
as part of the group and now we're
working down to the first nine groups
will bring us down to uh 50 year olds
and
inclu and people who um right down to 18
who have some medical condition
so those are being done now with the aim
that those first five
groups those first nine groups will be
done um
certainly by well they've sort of said
by mid-april i think but i think they
could easily be done
before that and then um obviously it has
been contested who gets it next
should it be prioritized in terms of
some occupations but it looks like
they're still deciding to
work down through the age groups and
following this scientific
discovery from a statistical analysis
that age is the absolutely dominant
factor
your risk of catching and dying from the
virus doubles for every six years you're
older
and so that that i think again is a very
science-based conclusion
and that would from what you say then on
that statistical basis professor
it would probably make sense for for the
government to continue on the
trajectory that it's on in other words
being age driven
yeah i think i think that's what what
they are doing clearly it's very
delicate because i can see that
certain professions we know um very
public facing professions do have a
higher risk but then if you were going
to do that you'd want to do
taxi drivers you'd want to do but you
know public transport jobs
all sorts of people would be then sort
of demanding
uh to be to be put up in the queue so
they have gone for
essentially keeping it quite simple i
mean they should have done men before
women for example of the same age but
you know they've tried to keep it as
simple as possible and i can understand
that
it's a bit like the tier system which
they don't want to go back to because
the complexity of that gave rise to so
many arguments
that i can see that they're preferring
to keep things just simple and just say
that's the way it's going and i think
what's also remarkable
there's no queue jumping you cannot just
get this vaccine you cannot even
know if you it's not like getting a test
if you pay money you could get a test
i i feel really proud of that i feel
deeply moved by the way we're all
standing in our queue and we're getting
our jabs
and you can't buy it the rich man i
don't think you can
i wouldn't dare anywhere on the black
market i mean who knows what would be in
the vial
exactly exactly are we getting evidence
in addition to uh preventing
uh going down with the covert
particularly going down
severely to an extent of hospitalization
the evidence for that
now assuming for the vaccine's efficacy
is quite strong
is there evidence too that it also
prevents transmission
yep it's growing now i mean
unfortunately the biggest effect
is for the nastiest things so we know
that hospitalization just from one dose
from this fantastic scottish study
showed a
85 reduction in hospitalizations from us
from um pfizer 94 percent from
astrazeneca
and i should add there's no difference
between those numbers
yes there you know it makes all
statistically there's no difference
no there's no difference at all you know
if you look at the we
statisticians would look at the margins
of error around those numbers
they completely overlap so there's no
basis for saying one is better for the
other
on the basis of that data that's
hospitalization that means
protection against dying even higher
than that
very like we still haven't not had that
many deaths following vaccination
and so uh it's very difficult to we're
not too confident about assessing that
exactly
but i'm sure it's above 90 percent
efficacy against against death
against infection and a against
some disease a little bit be a bit lower
than that it looks like about 80 in the
80
and it gets infection maybe you know 60
to 60 70
protection against infection growing
evidence for that
um and so and but it does depend on the
variant possibly
so though there is protection against
infection but even greater protection
against the more severe outcomes which
is what we're most interested in
it it's encouraging to see britain doing
well in this given all the mistakes that
were
about to be made around this time last
year which
has set us back of course it was
uncharted territory for every
body then but of course it it and
because you couldn't you know i'm sure
there's some people in britain will take
some
a certain comfort from the fact that
europe is making a bit of mess of things
in some areas
but of course we can't really be free
until our friends in europe are also
on the same trajectory as we are and
they're quite
far behind professor i mean i'm coming
to you from france
here they've only done seven percent and
and the president's
uh attacks on astrazeneca uh
have given the already quite a strong
anti-vaxx movement in france
a reason for not taking the astrazeneca
there are as we
speak uh about a million unused
astrazeneca doses this this is a
complete tragedy
and um i don't sure you know it's not
very polite to refer to a president of a
of a great country as an idiot but
really that
frankly is when he said oh it's
quasi-ineffective and over 65
was both totally wrong you know grossly
misleading
and has had apparently a big effect
people are don't want this astrazeneca
vaccine
which we're now seeing in real world is
doing fantastically well
so this is tragic this is costing
lives i mean vaccines it's not like
going into
you know super drug and deciding what
headache tablet i'm going to get
if you don't get this you're not going
to get a vaccine for some time
and so i've got relatives in italy in
their 70s
absolutely no sign of a vaccine coming
for them yet i mean this is
i think this is appalling and now you
know in britain we're working right down
to as we've heard
through younger and younger people and
this is having a huge effect
so as as you said we want everyone to be
vaccinated
so that we've we can restore some
confidence in traveling and
moving around so this is tragic and it's
going to cost a
very large number of lives in in in
mainland europe i think
it was more damaging i think in france
than people even in britain realize
because
attacking the astrazeneca one which is
the one that doesn't need special cold
storage
unlike the fisa one and yet france does
not have a nationwide chain
of the cold storage that could handle
the fisa so actually the astrazeneca
would have been better for them because
you don't need that uh cold storage
but even what we tend to think of
professor is the more
level-headed more pragmatic germans
they've kind of gone down this route
yeah it was their regulatory agencies
the european medicines agency did
approve
astrazeneca for over 65. on the same
basis as we did
that there was no evidence that it was
not effective
and a lot of in a way indirect evidence
that it was just from what we know about
vaccines what we saw about
the immune response it generated in
older people
and and so you know in a way the pr the
precautionary approach would be
to give it to the over 65 because
otherwise this is going to cost lives
but whereas many of the national um
regulatory agencies in germany and
elsewhere
thought oh we're going to be cautious
because we haven't got evidence that it
works so we're not going to approve it
well no that you know they're having now
they're changing their minds
too late you know they they brought up
distress in this
in this treatment and in this vaccine
and it's going to take a long time to
reverse that
that public opinion so it's a total
disaster
in terms of the processing of the
scientific evidence and the
communication of it
and as i said this country's made you
know one mess up after
after another in many ways but it you
know it's really good at this stage
with the variant the new variant
spreading you know
now throughout the rest of europe um
that we have at last done something
right
final question uh professor for today uh
if the royal law continues to be the
success it is in the good news about the
power
the efficacy of the vaccines continues
to come in
too should the government consider a
quicker exit from lockdown or should it
just be cautious
june isn't that far away let's not
get ahead of ourselves what would you
like you know you know
not to ask me what what the government
should do because i'm not going to say
and i have said i before you know a
number of times that
we are coming up to a massive argument
because the rate at which deaths for
example are coming down in this country
i don't think
what you know was more better than
anyone would have predicted i think
we're going to uh see i'm obviously
certain i think now before easter
um no excess deaths in this country that
the total death rate will be below
the five-year average and uh there will
be enormous demands to speed up the
release but i i do think
that we've got to be very cautious and i
think i i mean
they did say data not dates and then
said a whole lot of dates
i really i mean come on no but i think
you know so i'm going to say that they
should be looking at the data and being
called
let's see the result of opening up
schools let's see the result at each
step
i i mean the and and let's see what
let's see what happens
and and to be cautious because
especially
with the new variants coming along
there's a real risk of a big blow up
where we have protected the most
vulnerable but
if if it takes off among the
unvaccinated
we could still see a huge impact on on
on the health and we'd have to then
start closing things up again
and they don't want to do that they
certainly don't professor
president we're going to have to close
up but as always it's been a pleasure uh
having you on spectator tv thank you for
joining us
today that's uh cambridge university's
david spiegel halter
speaking to his uh one of our country's
top statisticians if not
the top statistician in fact ah i'm
still working with my abacus so i'm not
really quite in that league
yet let's get to the budget the uh the
giveaway chancellor was still giving
away
in this week's budget but there was a
later sting in the tale a huge rise in
taxes from 2023 onwards to help pay
for all this spending and to restore
some order
to the public finances in terms of the
annual borrowing amount
and the overall national debt which is
now in the trillions let's go
to get a briefing from our economics
correspondent kate andrews
thanks andrew this week the chancellor
presented his second budget to the house
rishi sunak at this point is uh no
stranger to splashing the cash
and this was no exception we got 65
billion pounds
of additional spending a lot of that's
going to go on immediate coveted relief
extending the furlough scheme till
september extending that uplift to
universal credit
business grants and much more but in
addition to the giveaways we also
got some tough pills to swallow in the
form of tax hikes
corporation tax is going up to 25
uh for big business by 2023 and there's
also been
a freeze to personal tax thresholds i'm
sure we're going to discuss that
after the slideshow but i want to look
at the office for budget responsibility
and what they published alongside
the budget because we got some updated
forecasts that gives us some insight
as to where we think the economy is
headed
and what we can make from that so as you
can see from this first slide the obr
have brought forward
their projection of reaching
pre-pandemic levels of gdp
uh to q2 next year it's not that much of
a change
it was expected to be q3 but it is
something um here you can see that big
contraction of 9.9
for 2020 this year we're expected to
grow by 4
next year really quite amazing 7 and
then returning to business as usual
after that with an
average of roughly 1.6 growth
now the reason that that percent is
there for this year reflects the fact
that we're going to be in a very strict
lockdown in winter and hopefully
be open and having a booming economy in
the summer
and data from the oecd which has been
analyzed by the spectator
has found that despite low levels of
covid in the uk compared to our european
counterparts the uk is not only one of
the most locked down countries
but it's also suffering from some of the
slowest gdp growth per week
if you compare our gdp to last year
now what this slide is is really showing
is that quite obviously the more locked
down you are the harder it is
to bounce back and and that means that
we're not going to have the same level
of growth
this year that we may potentially have
next year
but moving on um to other news from the
obr
really good news actually if we look at
unemployment originally the obr had
forecast 11.9 percent
to be the peak of unemployment and
that's fallen right down to 6.5 percent
this really boosts the credibility
of the furlough scheme and perhaps
explains why it's being extended
till september with hopes that with the
economy very open this summer conditions
will be better
for those furloughed workers many of
whom may discover their job doesn't
exist anymore
will be able to come into a jobs market
that is perhaps a bit
more active but none of this has been
cheap and as you can see here the debt
is now estimated to be
at 2.8 trillion pounds if deficit
projections are anything to go by it's
going to keep going up by quite a lot
public spending was up by a quarter in a
year
last year billion pounds borrowed in
2020 2021.
it's forecast for 2021 22 that's going
to be
234 billion pounds you can no longer say
that the cover crisis is a one-off
spending spree
by the time we get to 2024 or 2025 we're
still borrowing
estimated to be borrowing over a hundred
billion pounds
a year now some people will say that's
really not a problem because
look here at this slide how cheap it is
to
service that debt but there are still
several issues here
it's not just about the amount of debt
but the ratio of jet
of debt to gdp that really matters which
is now hovering just below 100
and second and perhaps this is the most
important slide actually to explain
this budget it's just how vulnerable we
are when it comes to servicing
that debt and that's what we're looking
at in this week's magazine the fear that
was playing on the chancellor's mind
when he decided to hike taxes and
present the budget that he did
because while conditions for borrowing
are extremely agreeable right now
if there's even the slightest bit of
movement historically low movement
as you can see here one percentage point
change in
interest rates guilt rates or in
inflation then we could be looking at a
25 billion pound
black hole that the chancellor would
have to fill
that's roughly finding the school's
budget if it's a two percentage point
increase that's finding the defense
budget and that could prove extremely
painful for the country
and very politically difficult for the
conservative party having to come up
with that money
in such a short period of time and so
it's it's this concern i think that has
really driven what you saw
in the budget this week which we can
discuss now so back over to you andrew
okay uh kate thank you for that for
these fascinating
charts i'm going to come back to the
economics of the budget
in a minute but let me come to our
political editor james forsyth and some
of the
the politics of this james is there now
talking westminster because
he's talking about you know no tax
increases for a while
but then from 2023 onwards there's quite
substantial increases both in
corporation tax and in household on
income tax
as well because the thresholds are going
to be frozen almost every threshold
is actually being frozen we thinking of
a 2023 election now
i i don't mean there is a firm date in
the government's mind when they want to
have the election but i think when you
heard the chance to read out the growth
forecast talking about you know 7
growth plus in 2022 then 1.7
in 2023 and then 1.6 1.5
you would you would it would be you
would surely want to have the election
as
close to about seven percent that year
of seven percent growth of a feel-good
factor
rather than have it after a couple of
years of 1.6
you know fairly anemic growth you know
solid but not spectacular
i also think the other the other
calculation that has shifted
is i think uh six months ago when the
government's handling of the pandemic
was being
widely panned public confidence was low
you would think the government would
want to hold the election as far away
from covert as possible
but as your discussion uh david spiegel
showed
you know that there is there is
something the government is now getting
right the vaccine rollout
and the uk might be able to get rid of
restrictions quicker than other european
countries get life back to normal
and so again you might have a kind of
kind of a kind of halo effect from that
that you would want to tap into in an
election campaign
and of course before the fixed term
parliament act which
sort of mandated except in special
circumstances
a five-year parliament four years i
think james was about the norm for most
parliaments wasn't it
yeah i mean the issue here is that this
would be three and a half years
essentially because i don't think anyone
wants to go to
the polls in the winter again as has
happened at the last election
so you would probably be talking about a
kind of classic may
2023 kind of date um but but you are
right you know normally
parliament only went the full five years
if a government was in trouble
think of john major in 1997 you know you
you clung on desperately in the hope
that something would turn up
but normally you look at margaret
thatcher government successful
governments like
tony blair successful governments like
to go after four years
fraser our editor of the the spectator i
i listened to the chancellor on the
today program
on radio 4 this morning and i thought it
came really unstuck
over corporation tax i mean to see what
your take is on this i mean
for 10 years when i interviewed tories
about the cost of the corporation tax
cuts they all said but they'll pay for
themselves you know there'll be a sort
of laffer curve effect
and we'll end up with more revenue
now that your chancellor is telling us
that if he ups corporation tax
um he'll take in more revenue than he
would otherwise
i mean both statements can't be right
can they
well we're certainly stretching the
elastic of what used to be
uh tory economics and i mean the the
people you were talking to andrew were
actually quite correct and
corporation tax did keep going down but
the revenue kept going up
now might it have gone up even higher
there are higher rates
the thing is that corporation tax was a
little bit of
a misleading indicator because the
actual burden of tax the companies face
has got a lot to do with the deductions
of what they can count off against tax
so what george osborne was quite good at
doing was lowering the headline rate of
corporation tax but also
taking away the deductions so companies
pretty much
ended up paying the same there's a very
interesting part in the obr documents
where they show exactly the ruse here
the rate went down but the outdoor
burden stayed high
so in a way the the the great giveaway
was never quite as generous
as it seemed now you could argue rishi
sunik's coming along saying look i'm
going to increase
the allowances i'm going to let you
write off 130 percent
of the value of machinery that you might
buy against tax
and isn't that generous that raises the
prospect of a kind of reversal of the
osborne years the
allowance is getting more generous even
though the rate is going up
but when you look at the obr's
calculations it shows you
but the rate is going up way way faster
than the allowances this is going to be
the biggest
increase in corporation tax since since
dennis healey
in 1974 and we're going to end up
with the with one of europe's heaviest
corporation taxers now what you can't
i mean richie sonic was asked on the
radio this morning
what have you stopped believing that if
you lower the tax
rates the yields might go up that was a
bit of a trick question because
somebody who is a supply side or in the
tory party would say that's only the
case for certain circumstances
the top rate of tax for example you
could lower that and the rate would
probably go up
but then again it's probably marginal
but the truth
which russia sunk wouldn't admit is that
corporation tax is one of the only taxes
he's got
to play with the manifesto stops him
increasing income tax and the prime
minister stops them
curtailing the spending because number
10 is a very spent happy administration
plural rishi sunak is his job to somehow
finance the spending being authorized in
number 10
but do it being banned from touching
most taxes apart from corporation tax
i suspect it won't raise nearly as much
money as he thinks
but unfortunately it's the only tool he
really has to play with
kate i was fascinated by your cover
story this week of the spectator and the
specter of inflection
because it is it has been the kind of uh
hovering in the background we've been in
this incredibly
benign atmosphere for so long that
governments can borrow at the lowest
possible interest rates the
cost of servicing the debt no i mean the
size of our national debt at the moment
is at wartime levels but the cost of
servicing the debt is a lot lower than
it was when our national debt was a lot
smaller
but that all changes if inflation was
was to come back
and that would make the bond markets
nervous and it would make
fiscal positions far less sustainable
and i was interested that you
you think the chancellor is worried
about this
absolutely there's been a lot of talk
leading up to the budget that the
chancellor might be raising taxes to pay
down the debt i don't think the
chancellor at the moment has such
lofty dreams this is about a much more
immediate concern
and that is that these conditions for
borrowing that are so agreeable at the
moment
only need to change just slightly for
him to be in a really difficult position
and weeks ago frankly the economic
consensus
seemed to be that everything was going
to be fine it would be rude not to
borrow this money
it's so cheap it's so cheap to service
the debt but something has started to
change
now you don't have major economists
coming out and predicting
inflation but you have very senior
people like larry summers who is by no
means
a fiscal hawk he was treasury secretary
under bill clinton
economic guru to barack obama in the
united states he's looking at joe
biden's 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package
which is going to land just as the
economy is booming open because the u.s
is
having a big vaccine success story at
the moment and he's saying this is
extremely risky we
may well be risking inflation and over
here you have the
chief economist of the bank of england
andy haldane releasing a speech last
week
all on this topic again not going so far
as to predict it
but he concludes by saying this is a
real possibility we are very vulnerable
we just don't know what happens when you
artificially suppress an economy
and then open the doors again we don't
have a playbook for this
so credible people are talking about it
and it's certainly weighing on the
chancellor's mind he wants to make sure
that if interest rates guilt yields
inflation
budge ever so slightly he's going to be
able to find as i showed in that graph
25 billion pounds potentially more
in order to cover it james
there have been movements in the bond
markets in recent days that corroborate
what kate
is saying but this if if this is now a
concern this goes way beyond
the british government i mean this place
to the heart
of the debt dynamics of the eurozone i
mean if you look at
france could now be heading towards a
debt
to gdp ratio of about 120
i think italy is already over 140 and
rising portugal's
not far behind spain is enormous as well
all that debt has been financed either
through european central bank
qe or being done by the governments
themselves because interest rates are so
low
and they've been able to get that debtor
away if what kate is saying is now
coming on to the
policy agenda that's a real problem for
the eurozone
yeah and i mean there are two two other
factors worth considering here one is
but the qe that followed the financial
crisis essentially went into repairing
banks balance sheets so it didn't really
go into the real economy
the qe that has happened during this
crisis has gone into consumers pockets
and also if you look at the amount of
savings that have been built up in this
country during the pandemic
you can quite easily see how when people
come out
you know there's a rush for home
improvements and the like and that
creates an
inflationary pressure then you add to
that as kate says you know
the us has the global reserve currency
so so it has
far more room for maneuver but it could
be you look at the size of this binding
stimulus and it could be about to inject
quite a sizable bit of inflation into
the world system i think you saw
the bank of japan getting nervous about
this you know this is going to be a big
issue and as you say
you know the eurozone you know it's
it i always think it's about the
eurozone we've stopped talking about
the euro because but its problems are
still there it's simply just in an acute
state
rather in a chronic state rather than an
acute state
if interest rates start rising you know
it could get
back into the acute state date really
quite fast
fraser you know over the years as we've
done our budget
uh uh shows in the aftermath and so on
we've
talked about uh how the government
from 2010 onwards was trying to get the
annual deficit down
bit by bit as a percentage of gdp was it
succeeding or
not and whatever it did of course
national debt uh continued to rise
of course all these figures we used to
be talking about an annual deficit of
about
you know 40 45 billion pounds i think
the one this year
is going to be over 300 billion
in your view given that the chancellor
does seem to be aware of the concerns
that kate was raising
is britain's fiscal position
as sustainable as it can be in the
current climate
it's difficult to say really i mean
could we have got away could we have got
through this crisis
with less debt i think the answer is
certainly we could have done if you look
at
the deficit that we had during 2020 the
uk was one of the worst hit countries
economically and that is linked to the
stringency
of lockdown not only was our economy hit
the worst but our debt
went up the most and the funny thing is
though that i think this budget was
written
not yesterday in the treasury but it was
written
when the government decided to extend
the most stringent lockdown in the world
as it currently is
for as long as they have done when you
extend furlough scheme until
september long after reopening is
supposed to be
going on when you start to answer every
single problem with a massive
massive spending splurge then you start
to create the biggest tax burden
in 50 years and that's what we've ended
up with
i think what rishi sunak is doing is
holding up a mirror
to the prime minister here saying look
this is the bill for everything that
you've promised
this is the bill for the toughest
lockdown in the world and
every week it continues it simply gets
more expensive and somebody's going to
have to pay
for that money so i think that we could
have got through this crisis
without doing um as much fiscal damage
as we did
but it's a bit too late now for that the
prime minister has tied himself to his
uh dates not data schedule of of moving
out
of lockdown and the bank of england has
also printed as much money as the
government has borrowed
so what we really don't know is what the
markets are going to think
of the continued hunger for deficit
spending after the bank of england stops
printing so we're about as stable as any
other european country right now which
is to say not very
no really no country really knows how
it's going to be until
first of all the quantitative easing
stops secondly the economy is rebound
and we can see how strong
that is and thirdly we wait for the
fallback from
joe biden's massive spending splurge
which could
trigger the inflationary wave he pours
lots of vodka
on the post-pandemic party that america
is about to have with a bailout which is
something like four times the size
of a stimulus that obama did after the
crash so we've got a lot of question
marks and a lot of questions that will
be answered
by the end of this year and kate that is
a concern
in london isn't it the size of the biden
stimulus
almost 2 trillion on top of what trump
had done and other spending
as well and as you look at some of the
supply side constraints already visible
in america
even labor in some constraint too uh
housing things you need to build houses
and all the rest of it
uh that's people are having trouble
sourcing
quite a lot supply chains already coming
under pressure
there's a fear as i understand that that
if inflation
kicks off in america as a result of this
that makes the danger all the worse for
britain oh certainly what happens in
america is going to affect the rest of
the world and as
andy haldane laid out in his speech last
week he says
and that what kept inflation so low for
so long those conditions have
fundamentally
changed we're not going to have another
china come onto the world market
uh for example and as you say andrew
globalization has taken a real hit
we just don't know how quickly it'll
come back if it's going to limp or
if it's going to if it's going to roar
back now before the budget
you had people saying rishi sunak is
going to use joe biden as cover
to to hike corporation tax to do these
big state things
because the president's doing it as well
and in the magazine this week i note
that a
a senior tory source says that's not
quite the case
in fact it's very very different from
that rishi sunak's not trying to be joe
biden he's trying to protect
from what joe biden might do to the uk
economy
because as friedrich hayek once famously
noted inflation is like a tiger and
you're trying to
chase it by its tail once the cat's out
of the bag it's it's near impossible to
catch so if things start to move
they can start to move really quickly
and now the key is that
nothing may change and that will be hard
for the chancellor if if his fears that
he's planning for
they don't become a reality people will
say well you were yet again overly
cautious you were too prudent this was
unnecessary pain
but if something were to change the
chancellor would be the person who
prepared for it
who planned for it and who tried to make
the uk slightly more resilient
to what might be happening in the states
or elsewhere
james let me come to you for a final
question this segment
my understanding is that the despite the
tax rises and all the rest of it that
the tory backbenchers are not in a
revolting mood
by and large they're either accepting it
or they're killing the
lips button for the moment but
if the election is to come in 2023
given the importance of the red wall
uh the seats that they won in 2019 old
labor seats that
some seats they had won for a generation
if ever
and they've got this leveling up agenda
as well with some money being spent
are they really going to be in a
position as they go around the red wall
constituencies by 2023
to say look at this improvement we've
done here look how this town center
is booming here look how we've cleared
these slums we've built
a new clinic you know all the things
will there really be visible signs like
that that they can say
this is a real improvement compared to
2019
i mean this is one of the big challenges
for them you know i think that
lots of voters in these red wall seats
take their state of their local high
street as a proxy
for is where they live better off than
it was
four years ago i think one of the
problems is covet has accelerated
all of the changes hitting the high
street you know the shift from
from from bricks and mortar retail to
online for instance
so i think they are going to have to do
kind of big planning reform to make the
high street more residential things like
that
i also think though that the public will
accept
that you know the government have lost a
whole bunch of time to covet i think one
of the challenges for
labor is you know they i think they
thought that they would be able to say
quite definitively at the next election
the tories have been in power for 14
years and once you've been in power for
14 years
essentially everything is your fault but
you know i mean how much longer do you
need to fix it
i think now the political argument will
be slightly different the government
will be talking about being two years
into its covid recovery plan
you know if it's this build back better
slogan so
i i think voters will get that you know
there has been an interruption
uh but i think as you say the particular
problem i think is that in these places
people will say well you know my local
high street and and that
that high streets have undoubtedly been
one of the things that hit
hardest by covert thank you for that uh
kate i think we can
release you and we're holding on to
james and fraser uh because we're going
to scotland now and the scottish drama
continues to unfold
this week nicholas sturgeon gave
evidence to the scottish parliamentary
inquiry
it's into how our government handled
sexual harassment complaints
against alex salmon and it ended of
course in total failure
and some substantial expense for the
scottish taxpayer
uh last week salmon had testified to
that inquiry this week it was nicholas
sturgeon
the inquiry however has been hamstrung
by the desire of the sturgeon government
to suppress essential information with
the willing complicity of the government
crown office which issues
it seems almost daily tourettes anybody
thinking of defying it
but this week the parliament did force
the publication of the government's own
legal advice and it proved to be pretty
devastating now look i understand it's a
complicated
murky tale but the spectator has all the
latest developments it's in
our new scotland home page and it's at
spectator dot co dot uk
scotland that's spectator dot co dot uk
scotland uh and you'll get all the stuff
we've been writing about this if you
really want to come up
to speed in this particular interest if
you live in scotland because you may be
getting a little bit of a different
perspective than to what the
local press has given you about this so
go to that
westminster may not be paying enough
attention but the spectator
certainly is north of the border let's
bring in our in-house journalists uh
following the story from the beginning
fraser and james are still here
uh and uh spectator contributor from
north of the bottom boulder
steven daisley stephen let me go to you
first
uh it's now 24 hours since
nicola sturgeon began her testimony
before the inquiry
what was the fallout this morning what
was the general
mood in the scottish media about how she
had done
well andrew i think if you peruse the
the newspapers in scotland this morning
um the the general line was that
uh there were still major questions uh
uh
looming over uh over nicholas sturgeon's
version of events
uh i think that uh you know i i have you
know said myself this morning and a
piece that i've
written for the the scottish daily mail
but i read it i read it i enjoyed it
well thank you very much uh you know the
point i made in that is that
i think nicolas sturgeon she gave if she
gave a lawyerly performance it wasn't a
theatrical performance like alex simon
gave
but it was a typically lawyerly
performance she she answered the
question she wanted to answer
and she didn't make you know i would say
she didn't make any major gaffes
in the room uh and i i would even i
would even add that i think that she did
succeed in casting some doubts on
aspects of alex simon's narrative you
know she
she kept making the point as to why
would i want to bring
uh such a huge scandal upon my own party
um and you know she uh i think that she
sort of managed to come across well
in a very legalistic sense however there
are still
uh major questions uh that
uh remain about uh about her evidence
and i would argue actually that
uh these questions are even um more
difficult
uh for her to answer and yet more
pressing for her to answer
as a result of yesterday so we heard
uh yesterday that uh you know nicholas
admitted that yes she had this
secret meeting with alex salmond at her
uh her private home in glasgow
it was on april the 2nd 2018. that's
correct
on easter monday 2018 and she
uh said that she believed this meeting
was
uh on party business her husband and
snp chief executive uh peter murrow had
previously testified that he
considered it to be scottish government
business now that's one of the
the major inconsistencies that was not
answered yesterday which one of them
um was was being accurate in their in
their description of the nature of the
meeting
the the next point was the failure to
disclose that meeting itself
now nicola sturgeon said yesterday that
she considered this
meeting to be a party political business
and then
she went on to uh to recount how alex
salmond had showed her a letter
he had received from the the permanent
secretary outlining allegations against
him and she spoke about
in some way her voice actually was sort
of breaking at points about
how shocked she was uh about the nature
of the allegations
yet and still she did not go from that
meeting at which it was very clear
you know certainly at least at the point
uh
that the that letter was handed over to
her there was now a government related
meeting
she did not go from there to tell the
the civil service i have just had a
meeting
and that is germane to this
investigation that came for and it was
another two months before she did that
now what she said yesterday was well she
was concerned doing that would have
jeopardized confidentiality and it would
have put civil servants in a sort of an
invidious position because technically
as
first minister she wasn't supposed to
know about this investigation
that is not something i think that is a
supportable or sustainable argument
and stephen having looked through the
scottish ministerial code
the ministerial code does not give her
that discretion
it doesn't say well but if there are
other considerations you don't need to
report it
it says you have to report it if it's a
government meeting you report it
absolutely and that point was made
yesterday in the committee and uh nickel
surgeon didn't really have an answer for
it and it is a
how do i put this politely is that it's
an innovative interpretation of the
scottish ministerial code
that there is some you know power for
the uh for the ministers who are bound
by it to decide
in the circumstances that uh that uh
that they have to comply with it
um i think that's a certainly a big
question that
came out yesterday another one um that i
i think we're going to be talking about
a lot more um down the line
is this claim that the name of one of
the complainants
um who had come forward to accuse alex
sammond was given
to an associate of mr simon to jeff
aberdeen his former chief of staff
in a meeting with a with a scottish
government official
now that claim and from alex salmond
uh from his camp that has
now received corroboration from kevin
pringle is a former
special adviser to the scottish
government and from duncan hamilton
uh who uh former snp msp and up also
uh now uh you know a particular
practitioner in law and he's a
very well respected qc these are our own
people these are snp people
they are and you know there is um i
think it's worth noting as well but
kevin pringle
who's you know so very very well
regarded across the political spectrum
and also across all the factions within
the snp he said in his statement to the
scottish government
you know he referred to a piece he
previously written in the sunday times
saying
that he wants justice uh or as he sees
it for alex salmond who wants the the
right thing
to be done but at the same time he has
no desire to see nicolas sturgeon
um you know not continuous first
minister so this is not a factional
thing
now but what hamilton and pringle's
evidence is important because
it does provide corroboration um to some
degree
of of what alex simon is claiming
and the question then becomes because
nicola sturgeon you know
she she makes the point that neither
pringle nor hamilton were in this
meeting and so they are just relaying
what jeff aberdeen told them
uh the question though then becomes well
what corroboration does nicola sturgeon
have
um because you know and it became clear
yesterday in
in the uh her exchanges with committee
members that
uh that there had not been uh any what
was sort of called
a formal sort of investigation process
or
fact-finding process to determine um
the uh what was said at the meeting from
the the scottish government
um senior official that has been
referred to
you know how you know if the salmon camp
can sort of
produce these two um sworn uh statements
by members of the snp
saying you know we were told that this
this happened that complainant's name
was was given to to jeff aberdeen which
you know
i think we're sort of we tend to breeze
by this that's a huge thing if that
happened that is an extraordinary breach
of confidence
um the question is sorry let me just
show you this
i'll come back to you of course but let
me just go to fraser
i watched most of the testimony
yesterday it was long i think it ended
up being about eight hours
and she started very strongly and there
were long periods when she was across
the brief so much so that she hardly
ever had to refer to the papers in front
of her
uh she was confident at times and she
had some detail
but as the afternoon went on and the
labor's jackie bailey and the tories
murdo fraser
uh the namesake fraser um
began to really needle her about
these meetings with with her aid in
early march and then
the meeting that she apparently had
forgotten about in late march
then leading to the meeting on april the
second that we've just been talking to
stephen about
she did seem more flustered and more
defensive
did you did you agree with that yes she
didn't have a good answer to that
question
and it was pretty obvious that this is
the issue where she is technically
most exposed on the dates which she gave
versus what we now know to be the truth
but your average scott might listen to
this and think well does it really
matter
that much if she had this meeting on the
second of april or the 28th
of march does it really matter that much
if the meeting was categorized as a
government meeting or a party meeting
if she got muddled over that she said at
one point in the evidence that she just
thought of easter monday she didn't
think of it
as what day in march or april it was
then is it really that big
a scandal are you really um saying she
ought to resign
because several years ago she got a
certain date
wrong but i think the s p would be quite
happy
if the overall question went in that
direction because the bigger
problem i think is something that we saw
earlier on tuesday
it's about the way this whole inquiry
has been conducted
and the way that the snp government is
basically behaving with impunity and
dodging the scrutiny
it's not so much the actual sin it's the
cover-up and the mechanisms of the
cover-up
which i think is so shocking for example
let's take the lord advocate he runs the
crown office
the prosecutors and scotland's answer of
the crown prosecution
service now the lord advocates who um
basically told the committee that they
had to censor
alex salmon's evidence that they'd
published so an incredible thing to say
and the crown office which is run by a
member of nicolas sturgeon's cabinet
is saying to the parliament no you can't
publish that evidence
and evidence which by the way the bit
that was censored just happens to be
rather embarrassing
for nicholas durgin so he was called in
front of the committee on tuesday and
asked to
explain himself but rather than being
apologetic the tone
of lord advocates and evidence really
showed you
just where power lies he told the msps
extraordinarily in my view but they were
punishable
so here you've got um a a member of
sturgeon's government informing
politicians that they are punishable
under the law
now what he meant by that was as opposed
to westminster where you can say what
you want
you can ask what you want in the
committee you don't have to worry about
being sued because you've got
parliamentary privilege
that privilege does not exist in
scotland
the msps are indeed vulnerable to being
punished
to use the lord advocates word by the
law if they're deemed to be in contempt
of court
and what's happening right now is
they're waiving the prospect of this
contempt of court bill saying you can't
identify the complainants
as being a device to try to chill
discussion to make people
nervous about what they say so the lord
advocates
overall approach i thought was
extraordinary he told the politicians
that they were punishable
but when they asked him if ministers are
punishable
if it's used alexander's example if you
didn't hand over documents when there
was a search warrant
asking you to hand over the documents
would that have been against the law
james wolf lord advocate he couldn't say
he said well that's a bit hypothetical
it's funny that he wasn't shy about
telling the msps that they were
punishable but the government
that seems to be a different matter
entirely so the overall impression we
get from this
inquiry is not really a debate about
who said what and what particular dates
important to that is
is the overall impression that a new
establishment has taken root
in scotland which is more powerful and
perhaps less accountable than the old
establishment ever was
james you've been watching this what are
what are your thoughts i thought she was
uh on the ropes a bit trying to explain
why she had not followed
the clear advice of her external counsel
her external counsel being the
leading qc in scotland dean of the
faculty of advocates it doesn't get
better than that north of the border
and she had trouble trying to explain
why
for so long the scottish government
seemed to know the fact that their case
was
going to hell in a handbasket yeah and i
think the real scandal here is is that
is the uh at one point rodney donald
complains of the extreme personal uh
professional embarrassment
but he and his junior on the case have
suffered and the crucial point is the
reason
why it's because the government is not
releasing documents until the very last
minute and these documents contradicted
things that have previously been told to
the court so
yes you can argue but they don't say
that the case
should be conceded until december but
they would have said that a lot earlier
if the correct documents have been
handed over to the court
as early as they should have been i mean
why that didn't happen is a big question
i i personally think on on on nicolas
sturgeon's testimony
i thought her weakest bit which which
she herself almost acknowledged
is forgetting universal commerce this
29th of march meeting with jeff aberdeen
in the scottish parliament when
she is told you know that alex salmond
wants to see her
and the kind of reason why i i i find
that bit
remarkable she talks about how shocked
she was in the meeting in her own home
but if you're told that someone wants a
meeting with you and that you you think
that that would lodge in your
memory and i think that is a a challenge
for her
we're meant to be getting more of the
legal advice later today
um and it'll be interesting to see
how that reflects compared to the
testimony she she has given
i mean my sense yesterday watching that
testimony is
that you know that this committee ain't
going to be able to come to a conclusion
it is too split down party lines
to write a report of any weight so i
think everything now
turns to james hamilton the qc who is
investigating
whether or not the ministerial code was
broken you know nicolas sturgeon is
clearly relying on that verdict she can
kept saying to the committee well that's
for james hamilton to decide on that
front
and i think i think i think what he
decides will be of
huge consequence now and also there's a
massive question about the timing of his
report
is that going to come out before
scottish voters go to the polls in may
you know
there is something rather unseemly about
the fact that nicola sturgeon
won't give firm dates in a lockdown map
but once
it wants to get this election happening
despite all the restrictions that are
remaining in place i think it suggests
that the snp don't think the situation
is going to develop to their advantage
if they maybe delayed that poll until
uh september stephen the
the scottish voters may find it quite
hard to go through
you know what's the significance of from
march the 29th to april the second it
was
almost three years ago now reporting
immediate party meeting government
meeting
but the hamilton inquiry uh by this
irish qc
uh he'll think it's important i mean he
is the
person appointed by the scottish
parliament of the scottish government to
enforce
the ministerial code so that is that
in some ways although the parliamentary
inquiries had all the police publicity
that could be a bigger threat to nicola
sturgeon and the parliamentary inquiry
yes i think that is i think that's
correct and that is a view
i should say andrew that has been uh
voiced to me by
uh msps of various parties for quite
some time now
i think the the view has been at
hollywood for
for for a while that the as james
referred to
this committee is just so split and
indeed it is so
hampered and not not just by the crown
office but actually by
it's very remit from the start and some
you know some might argue deliberately
um limited in its remit from the start
and so now
all eyes will turn to to james hamill to
know that
in fact there is a you know another
argument
as to whether his remit is broad enough
and because it does go to
specific questions about ways in which
the ministerial code
was was broken and not others and jackie
bailey who is a
as we've said a member of the the
hollywood committee she has previously
questioned
whether the the the james hamilton uh
inquiry should be
should be broader um i i think the the
thrust however is
is very much that you know james
hamilton
is uh is a very well respected um legal
minds former
you know irish prosecutor um very uh
very well respected i think in
brighton's thing he was originally
recruited to
this sort of independent uh investigator
role
at the scottish government by alex
salmond it was indeed recruited by mr
simon
and and and i think reappointed by
nicolas sturgeon
um we sort of we don't know because
as you say there hasn't been the same
publicity around it that the the
hamilton enquiry is not happening in in
sort of
real time on on sort of our televisions
and so it's difficult to know
and where he's going to come down but
you know again i think
yesterday some of the the remarks that
some of the testimony nicholas sturgeon
gave
you know particularly in this question
about informing
um the civil service about this meeting
um with alex salmond at which she
herself said she was given a copy or
handed a copy of a letter from the
permanent secretary alex salmond
and yet uh she took her another two
months to tell civil servants about that
i think it is
um it's difficult i'll put it this way
i'll be interested to see
um what james hamilton thinks of that um
but
because i think to come to the
conclusion that that is in some way
was in any way you know proper or or she
had no other choice
that you know opens huge questions about
the ministerial code
and not just at hollywood you know it
opens huge questions about ministers
right to interpret
uh and and almost if you like add little
asterisks
to to the um to the terms that bind them
and
the fallout from that is potentially
even bigger than this matter itself
yep the story still has way to run
that's for sure
inquiries going on the may elections
looming my instinct is that uh i mean
nicolas surgeon has
lived to fight another day she's
tenacious no question about that but
um it could be that she's going to be
heading to the may elections as the
walking wounded
and although it is almost certain she
will still be quote the winner
what has happened could well deny her an
overall majority
and that would have huge constitutional
significance
uh for a second referendum without an
overall majority
she will find it much harder to demand a
second referendum gentlemen we'll leave
it there
thank you for joining us we'll be back
the story goes on
but for the moment let's go to france uh
france has got another presidential
election
next year it seems can't believe it's
almost four years since president
emmanuel macron won the french
presidential election on a beautiful
spring night i remember being there in
paris
as he won comfortably over marine le pen
can he get re-elected next year french
terms are now only five years there used
to be
seven for president uh in this week's
spectator jonathan miller
who writes lots of great stuff for us
about friends he writes
about a potential challenger and eric
zamur if that's the right pronunciation
and he's a good he's a journalist and
uh that should be a disqualification
right away
some people call them francis tucker
carlson so because of the american fox
news guy
so jonathan i assume then if he's
friends is tucker carlson he's on the
right
well he is uh he's definitely not a
socialist that's for sure
he's um he's in some ways he's he's a
very interesting guy
he's uh from a family of algerian jews
he's
uh been very very controversial he wrote
a really very very good and sound
clever book about france and its decline
but needless to say some of the things
he had to say
proved very controversial and he's been
repeatedly attacked for being a
racialist
and fascist nevertheless he has a very
very good
style he writes for the figaro he
appears on an evening tv show
called sea news where he's extremely
intelligent very polite
he has a very good style a very good
rapport with
the guadalupe co-host christine kelly
and he's got quite a following um indeed
such a following that the polls say he
could get 13
in the first round of the french
presidential election next year
and what would that mean if he got
around 13
you know what am i allowed to say i
don't know
um no it's always hard to know because
the votes so split
over so many different people in the
first round it's it's it's
it's it's it's uh it's a sort of circus
maximus of
hopes and ambitions uh it has you know
candidates from the clown car
you know napoleonists and bourbonists
and animal rights people
i would put in parentheses i would
probably vote for the animal rights
people myself
as well as you know we can see that from
your dog that's behind you he's
feeding you all the best lines he
doesn't he don't he doesn't like me uh
zooming um you you know you've got uh
complexity on the left as well with uh
with uh
jean-luc melchio who's kind of the
jeremy corbyn
of france but it doesn't go away it's
forever
it doesn't go away it doesn't go away
well you know we'll get double digits of
votes
you have ann hidalgo the mayor of paris
uh
in the ring somewhere you might have had
nicolas sarkozy but
i think carla is measuring up for
curtains in
lassante prison at the moment he just
it's
probably unlikely he will go there but
um
if zuma was to run what would
be his appeal in in i mean is he going
to occupy some of the ground that
uh madame le pen and the the front
national or
well le pen is spitting bullets um i
mean uh
as of last weekend uh she was fasche
is the french verb to describe le pen
that anybody should dare
challenge her but more and more people
on the right know that she's a toxic
brand
she has a name that is associated with
her father who is really out and out
and anti-semite and and kind of a
very disreputable character even though
she's moderated herself
she's not really dare i say she's not
that clever
she she gets eaten alive on television
yes um she uh she often starts these
campaigns
fairly strongly according to the polls
but then she finishes
very poorly as she did last time if she
if it was the same
rerun this time of last time and it was
a le pen
macron race it's quite possible macron's
victory might not be so
overwhelming um but i
still cannot see a scenario i mean the
french people i know
and i know people lots of different
french people they're not extremists
they're not crazy
um and they don't want le pen as their
president and
much as they don't really like macron
very few people
really like him um he is the
quintessential lesser of two evils
however
macron was very confident this was how
it was going to play out
macron versus the pen again in the
second round
again you know winning um five more
years
uh fantastic except that um
this little virus has come along and it
really
it's a it's a fiasco in france um
you know we're not there are no vaccines
in sight around here
so he's vulnerable on that he's been
protected a lot by the french media
who've not made a big deal of this
um but it is becoming
clear that the virus is uh is not
controlled in france
infections are going up hospitalizations
are going up in paris in the east
and i think where you are you may be
having a weekend
lockdown soon oh the the that's happened
from 6 pm on a friday night to 6 a.m on
a monday morning
there is we had it last weekend and
we'll have it again
and there's talk of even more uh strict
or stricter rules to come into so i can
understand why that makes
uh mr macron vulnerable after all he's
meant to be a technocrat
so he's meant he's been to do these
things properly so can i
just stand stand back and is it possible
that zamur who may have more appeal on
the right
than le pen given all the heavy baggage
she carries with her
is it possible that he could be the one
that goes through to the second round
with uh mackerel
well everything's possible andrew i mean
that's possible it's also possible that
macron himself
might not make it to the second round
because the vote percentage votes are
always quite close together aren't they
there
it's it's a it's a circus um
you know this this system um
uh designed by de goal this two-round
system
um has a traditional history of throwing
out
candidates in the second round who were
not really
seen coming 18 months to a year before
these elections
all kinds of people who subsequently
ended up getting through to the second
round
did and some of them even became
president
including macron himself who 18
who 18 months out was seen only by the
most
perspicacious french commentators i
won't mention any names
as having any chance at all so it's a
delightful unpredictability of this
which makes it happy days for those of
us writing about french politics because
well that means
something to say i mean i mean and
macron did it because there was an
amazing confluence of factors took place
that suddenly undermined the center left
and the
center right traditional candidates and
he came through
the the middle as as the new member let
me ask you another way
if and you're quite right we don't know
it is a bit of a crap shoot then
who gets through to the second round but
if zamur
did get through to the second round and
it was a macron
zamur uh a playoff
would he am i right and thinking he
would be a more formidable
uh opponent than le pen for macro it's
possible but the trouble with zamor
as much as zuma is a charming smart
guy even if he has a talent for annoying
people who
i confess i'm happy to see him annoy
he's a little limited he's a bit
conventional he's a bit
french on the economic side i mean
france
is sort of there's a sign on on on
railway
level crossings here one train can hide
another
and really one crisis can hide another
this this
this virus is hiding this mult these
multiple
uh crises that are confronting france
and on these crises
it's fair to say that some more has not
had
great things to say he's kind of a
combative he's kind of a traditional
big serious approach you know
you know the tgv was brilliant you know
the nuclear power stations were possible
they probably were
in their time but unleashing the genius
of french people
and their incredible talent and
innovation and technical
uh mastery of all kinds of difficult
subjects
unleashing that from the dead hand of
the state
well that's kind of to me been the
challenge for the last
20 30 years it seems never to have
happened
and um you know i wish if i
you know were asked by someone what do i
need to do
you really need to have a more rounded
policy of you know
le pen was very weak on this last time
against macron
macron had all these things to say about
the economy and slimming down the state
and creating enterprise which all
sounded pretty good very few of which
he's actually succeeded in doing
by the way but nevertheless he said them
whereas le pen didn't really have much
to say
on the economy at all except not fully
thought out plans to leave the euro
which you know which is a very
complicated subject she never really
some of her economic policies weren't
that different from millions
no in fact you know i i you know it's a
bit trite but she's kind of a
nationalist
and a socialist i won't say that she's a
national socialist she's not a nazi
much but she is a socialist nationalist
i mean she
she she carries with her all that
baggage
of of that generation of french people
who think that the state is you know a
tatisma
the state is you know the answer to
everything and
these days it's that's unlikely indeed
jonathan we'll leave it there but it
sounds
like you're not going to be short of
things to write about forest in the
weeks and months ahead
thank you for joining us take care
andrew bye
the south of france uh and he thanks all
of our guests
and once again a very special thanks to
our sponsor charles stanley
for sponsoring the week in 60 minutes
charles stanley
is one of the uk's leading wealth
management firms it's one of the oldest
firms
on the london stock exchange as always
send any thoughts to spectator tv at
spectator dot co dot uk
and of course join us again next week
bye bye
[Music]
you